hurricane irma is barreling towards
florida after destroying lives and homes
in the northern caribbean
new video shows widespread destruction
across the region at least 10 people
have died including eight on the resort
island of saint martin irma is slamming
the northern dominican republic this
morning after tearing through puerto
rico yesterday it's still a category
five storm with top sustained winds of
180 miles per hour and it is on track to
hit miami early sunday one estimate says
37 million people could be affected
along irma's expected path mark
straussman and elaine quijano are in
south florida where people are rushing
to get out lonnie quinn is here with the
latest forecast but first let's go to
tony decouple he's in puerto rico where
irma's ipas just offshore tony good
morning
good morning well the tailwinds are
still blowing as about 900 thousand
puerto ricans wake up this morning
without power and many of them are in
little villages like this one on the
extreme northeastern end of the island
and as we survey the damage we're seeing
a lot of this we've got power lines
draped over other power lines and in
some cases we're being really careful at
the moment power lines just dangling
down and blowing in the wind
185 mile per hour winds pounded the
northern leeward islands wednesday
leaving behind a trail of debris and
devastation
the string of popular vacation islands
were smashed by irma in barbuda the
prime minister said nearly 60 percent of
his people are now homeless
st martin's famous airport home to
dramatic beach flyovers is said to be in
ruins here in puerto rico the island
home to 3.4 million americans narrowly
avoided a direct landfall but with a
storm as powerful as irma even a side
swipe is catastrophic we need to take
the people out of the building
everybody's going to be out of every
room we're going room by room this is
like something i thought we never
experienced we were evacuated from our
room along with vacationers like dave
collins of las vegas to take shelter in
the safest part of the resort we're in
the ballroom where people are lined up
for dinner and suddenly water started
dropping heavily from the ceiling
and they're afraid now the roof is going
to potentially cave in over here a
ceiling tile just fell from there and
you can hear the water
just
cascading down next time i'm going to
look at the weather before i make my
vacation clothes jose santana spent the
night here with his family but is
worried about what they'll discover
outside i can only imagine what the
little house is by the coast and the
little villages must be like right now
so our prayers and thoughts with you
know all of the families
yeah as officials here in puerto rico
begin to survey the damage the pictures
and the data that comes back is a
warning to everybody in south florida
right now one a professor at mit and
hurricane expert calculated the energy
in irma and he came up with 7 trillion
watts to put that in perspective that's
about twice the energy used in all the
bombs in world war ii nora wow an
important warning there tony to copel in
puerto rico thank you for your reporting